have you heard anything about the app
do you know if they're doing the app
it better be doing the app I don't know
look I just learned I just learned about
Discord app so
what other apps do I need to get while
I'm here you're asking us well it seems
like by now the Bonner app would be up
to date and you know
has it not been updated
um
really as far as I know it hadn't
well there's something uh shaking these
had no app either
that would be stunning
yeah especially because you know they
don't do printed schedules anymore and
they always said oh go to the app but if
there's no app
you know what
you know I just searched my this is how
stupid I am and I'm not paying attention
I went to my App Store and I searched
Barry
I don't know why what'd you find I don't
know it got out immediately
all right I'm download I'm downloading
the app now you sure it just doesn't
need to be updated
it needs to be updated but
um have they said anything about it or
like is it getting updated I don't know
uh keep on using Thank You Live Nation
oh my God Taco this is last year's
lineup yeah
I mean we're you've got to be kidding me
this is really sort of shocking man
that's why I wanted to bring it up I
didn't know if you've heard anything or
if there's been a uh anything said
well Barry get on this I'm sending an
email or text right now this is really
surprising
and actually this is a this I mean the
way that this is set up from last year
it actually looks better than it did in
years past this is a little bit easier
of a navigation
easier to navigate whatever word I'm
trying to say it just feels easier than
years past doesn't it
it was better last year yeah it was
pretty good
um real quiz okay I mean yeah this is
stunning I'm I'm actually shocked by
this
but then they do the damn schedule wrong
again I can't I can't with this the the
way that they make this schedule left to
right man
um and nowhere else in this Festival do
they list the schedule left to right
except on the website in their app why
do they do that
top down top bottom it's that's where
that's how it's done everywhere else why
do they make me go left to right and
it's so confusing oh all right I'm this
is really surprising so Barry get on
that if you can sending text now